good morning it gets tuesday so every
doesn't miss midge binds to you but I
really do think books make the best
gifts because they last I mean obviously
the stories last in your mind but the
books themselves often do too I mean I
still have the copy of Tom Sawyer mom
gave to me when I was ten but which
books to give well it's hard to go wrong
although not impossible but I have some
recommendations for you this holiday
season first my favorite book of the
year between the world and me by Tana
Aussie coats a short relentless and
brilliant meditation on race and history
in the United States also in the
recommended to everyone on earth
category the white boy shuffle by Paul
Beatty
this book is almost twenty years old but
it still is hilarious and frenetic and
heartbreaking as ever and I really think
it should be a classic I've never
recommended it to anyone who didn't love
it ok moving on for the person in your
life who loves reading but thinks they
hate classics death comes for the
archbishop by Willa Cather and the color
purple by Alice Walker both these books
are captivating in-page journey and
intensely moving despite being read in
schools for graphic novels fans Alison
Bechdel's are you my mother is the
perfect gift for your mother provided
that you and your mother have a very
very dysfunctional relationship and also
recommend city of clowns illustrated by
Sheila Alvarado and written by Daniel
Aragon who beat me in 1994 in our high
schools creative writing contest
she's since gone on to even greater
things including this brilliant story
about a young journalist in Peru
grieving his father then we have Eugenia
Porter's book beauty from ashes which I
highly recommend because it is the place
where I store my whisky flask if you
have a giftie who likes quote unquote
literary fiction for quote-unquote
adults I have several recommendations
beginning with hanya yanagihara her
first novel was a very strange book with
a deeply unreliable narrator who
discovers the secret to eternal life is
drinking the blood of a certain kind of
turtle it's excellent but her new book a
little life is even better I mean if you
thought the Fault in Our Stars was said
this is sad an older book I always like
to recommend Gilead by Marilyn Robinson
which is both an excellent novel and
kind of a religious one which is a very
rare combination in my experience and
now there's a brief history of seven
killings by Marlon James which is just a
brilliant novel that uses an oral
history format to tell this massive
sprawling story that all revolves around
the shooting of Bob Marley in Jamaica in
1976 for science fiction fans are also
fans of a brief history of seven
killings I recommend Nala Hopkinson
'he's midnight robber which is set in a
world colonized by Caribbean peoples
it's really stuck with me and I've just
started her book of stories falling in
love with Tom
which is a great title and so far also a
great book ok books about art and being
an artist here and I both really love
the flamethrowers by Rachel Kushner
and we also have just kids by Patti
Smith which I can't find my copy of
because ever since we moved my home
library has been very poorly cataloged
religion anyone who wants to understand
Islamic history or contemporary Islamic
thought and practice should really read
no god but God by reza aslan over the
years i've read and reviewed dozens of
introductions to islamic history this is
my favorite history I loved Mary beards
recent history of ancient Rome spqr
although sadly it is also lost somewhere
in our home library for poetry fans this
year I read two books of poetry I
absolutely loved a thousand mornings by
Mary Oliver and faithful and virtuous
night by Louise look Glick Glueck I
don't know both these books are full of
precise and profound poems that are
moving without ever being pretentious
young adult novels I don't learn enough
why this year but two recent books I
really enjoyed first and then by Emma
Mills aka elmify on YouTube which is
funny and my kind of romance II and the
boy in the black suit by Jason Reynolds
which is about a young man who's worn a
black suit every day since his mother
died also it occurs to me there may be a
new generation of wire readers who
haven't read a bunch of books published
10 or more years ago so I have some
recommendations on that front valiant a
modern tale of fairy by Holly black all
don't live by matt de la pena the truth
about forever by Sarah Dessen and speak
by Laurie Halse Anderson those are very
different books they probably be called
respectively a fantasy a sports book of
romance and a contemporary realistic
book but they all make great gifts and
with book gets of a big fan of bundling
different kinds of things together for
younger kids say 10 to 14 I really love
Jacqueline Woodson's miracles boys and
lastly Henry two favorite books this
year were last stop on Market Street by
Christian Robinson and the affirmation
Matt de la pena and the adorable boot
and shoe by Marla Frazee you can find
links to all these books in the
doobly-doo hank full disclosure you're
getting some of these for Christmas so
get excited I'll see you on Friday